we do know that he was known up to a
point to the intelligence Services I'm
sure we'll get more information about
him over the next few days and over the
next few weeks the Home Secretary
cautious on the day after the bombing in
May 2017. since then a lot has emerged
about Salman abedi's extremist
connections
he grew up in South Manchester in a
community of libyans among them a high
number of young Islamic extremists
leaving to fight in Syria and Libya any
young person who's been abroad to fight
in a battlefield should be someone that
should be paid attention to because if
you look at what that means for the
individual in terms of the connections
they built in terms of the experience
that they have you bring that person
back with a very violent potential and
volatile background to our Pacific
environments and that can lead to all
sorts of problems abedi's father Ramadan
had extremist views so too his younger
brother Hashem he helped build the arena
bomb and is serving life in prison they
all joined rebels fighting Libyan
dictator Colonel Gaddafi in 2011. a
convicted terrorist Abdul Ralph Abdallah
was a friend a baby visited and phoned
him in jail Raphael hosti was another
acquaintance he recruited Fighters for
Isis
the group was on mi5's radar on and off
for many years in 2014 MI5 first
identified a baby as a subject of
interest but closed his file four months
later
in 2017 a baby and his family traveled
to Libya on a one-way ticket MI5
assessed him again
a month later the security service set
up a meeting to reassess a baby's threat
but two weeks before the meeting abedi
returned to the UK and four days later
he detonated his bomb
the report said MI5 received two bits of
intelligence which if followed up might
have identified a baby as a serious
terrorist and it might have helped them
prevent the bombing the inquiry chairman
said that MI5 officers recognized that
some of the information at least
indicated potential Terror activity but
they dithered over it and didn't pass it
on to counter-terror police those two
key bits of intelligence were discussed
in secret and will stay that way it
means that the father of one victim that
families still haven't been told the
truth Martin brunt Sky News